hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and I
have a bone to pick with one angry video
game nerd at least once a week one of
your fans comments on my video saying
that I am very similar to you oh yeah an
angry critic who's obsessed with the
past
never seen one of those before but the
fact of the matter is these comparisons
keep coming and coming and coming as
both you and I know there is no
comparison I am by far the greater
talent I mean you may have reviewed bad
video games but I reviewed bad movies
based on bam video games which is far
worse you may have reviewed the third
Ninja Turtles movie but I have the curse
to review all three in a row ps4 but
focus is still copyrighted and you may
have beaten the shit out of Bugs Bunny
but that's nothing here's a taste of
what I do to myself and that's what I
can do to me just imagine what I can do
to you so I say to you Angry Video Game
Nerd if that is your real name
keep your fans under control you don't
see my fans leaving threatening comments
all over your videos like they should be
so please leave this petty jealous rage
behind you and simply acknowledge that
I'm the better man if you accept this
defeat please respond by leaving
absolutely no comment whatsoever in fact
don't even respond to this video in fact
act like you have a million other things
going on in your life that you wouldn't
even have time to watch this video let
alone respond to it do that and I will
accept your apology
but if there are any more outbursts out
of you mister video game nerd I swear to
god there will be words I will buy some
more words followed by maybe a few more
words and then topped off with that's
what I am talking nerd a critic action
and I assure you it will not be pretty
it will be very unpretty a bowl I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to
the angry Nintendo nerd